now to the growing safety concerns over
America's Railways for the fourth time
in just over a month a Norfolk Southern
Train has derailed some 30 cars went off
the tracks this one in Calhoun County
Alabama yesterday now officials say
there was no risk to the public this
latest incident came just hours before
the company CEO his name is Alan Shaw
was grilled by a senate committee about
the toxic train derailment in East
Palestine Ohio last month Roxanna siberi
has more on that part of the story
I want to begin today by expressing how
deeply sorry
I am Norfolk Southern CEO Alan Shaw
struck an apologetic tone Thursday
morning will you commit to paying for
long-term medical testing for people in
the impacted communities I'm commended
to doing what's right but when pressed
on exactly what that would look like he
did not offer specifics will you commit
to
ensuring that these families these
innocent families do not lose their life
savings in their homes and small
businesses the right thing to do is to
say yes we will Senator I'm committed to
doing what's right for the community
this week the NTSB began investigating
the rail operator's culture of safety we
are committed to the legislative intent
to make rail safer Norfolk Southern runs
a safe railroad a Norfolk Southern
earnings report from last quarter shows
the company's accident rate has risen
each of the last four years NCBS news
has obtained a union complaint filed
against Norfolk Southern last year
alleging unsafe practices throughout
Ohio I think with transparency you have
trust and unfortunately we really
haven't had that up until this point
Jessica conard and Misty Allison
traveled all the way from East Palestine
to Washington DC to attend the hearing
what did you think of the apology by
Alan Shaw
it's great to have an apology but an
apology has to have action behind it
they like so many others in that town
fear for their family's health it's
really impacted my seven-year-old and
even he said Mommy am I going to die
from being here and that just absolutely
broke my heart for CBS mornings I'm
Roxanna saberi